[Music]
we're going to have to make a decision
about human nature
to it
is this our home
to be cherished and nurtured an
incredible pearl flung out in a universe
of ashes and darkness
or
is this a hell world
a tiny confining prison at the edge of a
dying universe from which it is our
destiny to break free and recover our
higher and hidden nature from which we
have become separated
you know this is a choice which as a
culture we face are we to go into the
divine imagination
and create
you know starships the size of manitoba
that will ply between here and andromeda
and exist in a world of our complete
syntactical self-expression
or is man's place humbler
than that is that grandiose steeped with
megalomania touched with the kind of uh
political taint that's had this raping
and pillaging ever since we got out of
those miserable icebound villages in
jupland or wherever it was
is it that
or is it our challenge and our destiny
it's really a choice about human nature
as individuals and i guess this
is really
for you personally maybe what makes
this all important
as individuals we have been too willing
to be taught and led
when
what is really out there to blow your
mind is not some regurgitation
of previously achieved conclusions
but experience
the world is far weirder
than the maddest among us suppose
this very small flute theme called
bohemianism
just will not die
in western civilization you know it's
always been there it was there before
rave
before punk before rock and roll before
jazz before
the impressionists before the romantics
back back back there was always this
strain of descent because it's the
lifeline of sanity
and every time
the bastions of
bullshittery grow weak
the bohemian
thread
expands
its options offers itself
as an alternative and i don't think this
is an eternal
dance of frustration i think eventually
this
archaic
return
which is what this bohemian thing has
always represented will be felt
will be heard we have very little time
now
if i believed that salvation had to come
from political institutions
i would just throw up my hands and
despair it's very hard for people
sometimes to figure out whether i'm an
optimist
let's get something straight here
i am
the most optimistic person you have ever
met
i'm absolutely convinced that there is
nothing wrong
and that nothing can go wrong and that
nothing will go wrong and that if
something needs to be done
you will find yourself
doing it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you